one of the risks of social life is that
we will in the palace of an evening or
in the kitchen at a party end up trapped
with a person of excessive conviction or
to put it more colloquially a boar boars
can be found harboring any manner of
obsessions they may be deeply concerned
about grammar and the ever increasing
misuse of the subjunctive or believe
that modern architecture is alienated as
from ourselves they may be horrified by
the predatory nature of contemporary
capitalism or disgusted by the winning
of the environmental movement
they might hate feminism or see misogyny
in every corner of life boars aren't
necessarily wholly misguided
they may be making some very good points
along the way but our discomfort in
their company arises from the intensity
and relentlessness of their manner we
long that they might fall silent or more
realistically just allow us to run away
part of the reason why boars boar is
that we sense they're not being entirely
honest with us
they're certainly upset but the real
reasons why don't seem on offer we feel
in the midst of their explanations that
their intensity is drawing heat from a
source beyond the argument as they
define it they may well be emphasizing a
range of studiously impersonal political
economic or social factors but we insure
it that there must be a more personal
story from which we and they're
conscious selves have been carefully
shielded it's a general truth in no way
humiliating that our seemingly objective
adult concerns often have their roots in
incidents of personal vulnerability that
unfolded long ago and that may be
awkward to recover and discuss perhaps
when we were young our father lost his
job to a corporation that relocated
their offices to Southeast Asia the
payoff was relatively generous but the
shame intense for the family or perhaps
we've been passed over for promotion
many times by young and conspicuously
fashionable management team with an
interest in contemporary design or maybe
there was once a woman who liked very
much who was doing a PhD in Gender
Studies on the work of Julia Kristeva
who showed signs of interest but then
went off with a rival it left us quite
upset for a while we may not like to
remember these
let alone tell new acquaintances about
them at parties yet they are still
active within us and seek some way
however disguised of expressing
themselves but all we know consciously
is that capitalism is the most abusive
and unsustainable economic system ever
devised that modern architecture has
shamefully forgotten the nobility of the
classical tradition as embodied by the
works of romantic and Schinkel and that
feminists are out to systematically
destroy the foundations of male earning
power in advanced economies when we come
across such ardent views it isn't that
we want to hear less it's rather that we
would ideally want to hear more but in
another direction inwards rather than
further into socio-cultural and economic
abstractions and we want to do this
not from pruriens but because social
life is guided by a wish to encounter
the reality of other people which is
here being arcane li denied our boredom
is a base and impatient resentment at
being held at bay from the genuine
Cromer's of another's life the bore is
never just other people it is in given
areas also always us when we take a
psychological audit of our intellectual
ideas we all stand to discover that some
of our concerns though their intensity
to personal experiences which are hard
to define and frightening to own up to
this alerts us to how we might in the
future respond to the speeches of the
overzealous the task isn't to engage
head-on with a matter
apparently at stake it's to gently try
to shift the conversation away from its
official target to its origins
sympathetically asking when the issue
first emerge and what more personal
associations might surround it even if
we never quite get there the knowledge
of the structure of the problem should
make us careful not to try and engage
people of excessive conviction in too
many prolonged head-to-head arguments
there is no point trying to list why
capitalism is not the worst system ever
devised by modern architecture does have
its high points and why feminism remains
necessary this would be to believe that
the others rage was a kind of
intellectual error that could be
magically resolved through one or two
deft ideas that kind conversationalist
more compassionately pessimistic they
accept that the roots of certain of our
convictions like deeply tangled in
frightened anxious parts of the psyche
unlikely to be accessible outside
psychotherapy
we're so aware that it could sound
patronizing to treat people as less
self-aware and they believe themselves
to be that we overlook that it may
sometimes be also the height of
generosity to keep in mind the
complicated role that denied personal
wounds play in our art and convictions
and we hope that others will repay us
the favor the next time we find
ourselves delivering long and ever more
intense speeches by the decline in
handshaking the colonization of Ecuador
or the corruption of the English
language did you know that the school of
life is actually a place ten places in
fact campuses all over the world from
Melbourne to London Taipei to Istanbul
with classes and books and lots more
please click on the link below to
explore more